[Music]
dv
from cannes latinoamericanos for the best
sensation in the world mexico from division
manuel espinoza balfour making homero
simpson money and spanish the dream - without
egg
little demon I'm going to reply to you
little sensual pleasure flanders
I feel like I'm humberto vélez who  fall
that was slimy
I'm not positioned from your body I'm
just the ball just mere the meager 1 now
if not this is my turn
ok I'm humberto vélez if I leave today I'm
humberto vélez I'm a voice actor and
I'm very happy to be here
I want to share something with you, look how
he left me, he's homer, he's a fool, but it
's a caricature point, part
Serbian, but apart from that, he's free, and not that, if
you realize today, he speaks
uncontrollably, sometimes he screams, sometimes he
cries, sometimes he laughs,
so to the point  turns it into a
caricature turns it into that nervous and
libidinous interposed goals there all
uncontrolled and screams
that is more or less the formation of the
character of mere feel
for f  please aliens don't eat me
I have a wife and children eating
them as you convert Homer Simpson
is impossible and a joke told in English
is understood in Latin America because nothing
is the same in Latin America there are more than 21
totally different countries all of them
[Applause]
by force you have  to make a
tropicalization because to convert that to
our warm atmosphere of laughter much
easier of more aggressiveness in the
jokes of more explosion in those of the
situations that it gives was difficult
for example a phrase came one day in a
chapter the semantic load of what
I said there it was very local, that is, it was very
North American
[Music]
we had to play something that was as
crazy as that and apart from everything
that caused laughter as I scanned my
brain and looking for that scan month
I found a phrase that a friend of
mine said  so i put it i want to get
healthy and half the planet burst out laughing
and the recording an idiot this is latin
echo homer simpson is so popular  r because he
is one of us
homer simpson he tries everything and in everything he
fails in that he differs from you in
that this difference from me we
try everything in everything unsuccessful and
trying is the first step towards
failure as you are not going to identify with
a  character that appears on TV you see him
and you say
that's me
i
[Music]
what are the duties personal mercedes
street the world to play for animation
celebration trees or this saying in
this different way in the guayarmina
valdés fruit trees of ball  volley of
windows rector of silk ual sought
advantage for him
[Music]
from angeli to one million mexicans and
selling charlize theron robert del
iphone puebla where we are from in this
world the flame por forma com from the
food that I know like the views
my families come produce mole mole
poblano to the assumption
forster rogers now to business is bombay
three generations waves of movement
major under my mother in me
grind chang min those web talk about
wi  lliams
happy in their countries in knowing in puddle
I am a racing increase in six months
winehouse or the ingredients in the
menstrual big hamster
that's very very strong to sell
our people
marley that our hands
in an economic alliance where they are
shows coordinate happy in the show
the teeth
the slice version a shooting star in da
muller the show the rating is an accomplice in
its ratings dow jones in its rating I
am now received and textiles
[Music]
the hash had a program they followed
products we tried them if what it
lacks we put
mayweather  mutún and york broke la puebla
in the night in heaven is hard southern
air mouse you feedback
I got here I worked in the
factory but well I didn't have enough
money to pay rent and I already started to
do and I started to say in the factory no well
I make mole and they told me well,
bring a pound and I would start
preparing it as we prepared it ai in
Mexico they sell works discomfort in
leasing demolition is b  ien write
in bodegas in mexico néstor in our
and care network in the distillery in use
in a big way against longing by eaves
shawn i have out make up i have to go
in the sax yesterday in new york city these
people
demonstrated because of a problem with that
blanch line  affable followers she gives you a
briber expression to the soul of the truth and
the law in the state the in the relatives
of transfers we are leaving the middle
[Music]
of chinampas
in the militia
representatives of china go from
artificial island fields and avant-garde
text only forums  to volcanoes only
important to be of sculpture and space of
examination showed charlene in the maximum in
really rich they are of pesos progression
of the country is great
the benefits of this crop is that they
are natural they do not bring anything chemical
everything is natural mainly
organic matter  that is extracted from the
channels since it is new is a good
way to see with the latter that in
this one many nutri technical underworld escaped extinction
entities for the plants that
are for vegetables and also for flowers
the girl passes at the beginning it is very
difficult because you have to have day laborers
because the important thing is money vikas in
ways the actor way hair workers of
fun although this end but it depends
on a series function helps  of an Iberian
performance of the postiguet feeling in
both previous phrases integration is the
great success of the series
- between Jorge Vallejo in defending the but it
is calm or in Mexico if you take it they
keep in Mexico the tablets in the
bastion content is true names from
six to nine  respective numbers
restaurants this guy el rodeo i really
want to be part of the change
diawara bastion of interference work with
with frank and roldán and of organic order
atlistas natural it is possible it is impossible
the dates of factories and neighbors well
have to understand only hours no more
nothing  I am that it is important not with
walk with the farmers propulsive play on
my part I am in the field of
entities
the video with his progress plan
china fraud for farmers in included mind of
16 wild turkey wind and frank
feys 'tablets' with chinampas talks very
different from confuses chinampas web
I won climbing through network
explosion for no dish of farmers in
trying in help  the fighter of chinampas
we believe that the farmers yesterday
critics about the cndh in the software
for health software of china a country of
symbol or physics in agriculture with
other people hub a game awards
xochimilco used to be more than the with
the risk
[Music]
ah
this is our religion it is our
way of thinking
when I play I don't play
when I play I leave my body
so that the energy of my ancestors
can manifest physically in
this plane what I feel for
sport is a lot of love this  breakfast this
I know I'm not dead
this since he paid me
howard riddle is news girl and for him
in tarbes world soccer román escuer
plans for cold mesoamerican holding
mon  ex
[Music]
game in armando this moment my name
is armando osorio and I dedicate myself to spreading
the ball game in mexico and in other
countries it
is an invasion game where I
have to keep taking the opponent out of his own court
until I get the ball  through the
middle of the baseline that they
have
i know who i am
roberto
the ball is made of solid rubber
from a nail tree
the hardest part of this game is the
start because you get very
big bruises very very big bruises
ago  about three years ago we were four
teams last year I called
all the states we were already eight and right
now we are already 17 states
hello my name is queen maría puig shift
and I dedicate myself to the ball game
this sport is both male
and female and we decided  in this
sport take it in duality as
our ancestors have not inherited it
so I feel very happy that
both men and women have
the same ability to play this sport
for me it is very important because it is a
legacy that we are going to leave to our
children to our children to
our children's children the
ultimate goal of this sport is that there is
a contribution from society it is
for me my biggest dream would be  that
these young people could receive scholarships to be
able to have another economic level and
have an opportunity in society
[Music]
when the holy inquisition came it was that they
began to prohibit that sport if it
had not been prohibited by them right
now it was the sport more famous
than soccer  the ultimate goal of this sport
is to be able to make a professional league what
football is like
[Music
] sport is more than just a sport it
is a fashion it is sport